there are dozens of House Republicans
you have seen them in the recent moments
getting off the buses they are at the
southern border right now fox has
confirmed that next week the much
discussed impeachment hearing for
Alejandro mayorcas who's in charge of
our border with the homeland security
under his watch that hearing for his
impeachment is going to get underway so
moments ago K Jean Pierre blamed
Republicans for the record surge every
day every month is a new record in the
numbers of people who cross our border
we're about to hear from that group of
lawmakers they're Gathering right now on
the border we're going to bring that to
you live but first we want to get a
preview with our national correspondent
On the Border Bill maluan hi Bill good
to see
you Martha good afternoon to you that
delegation of Republicans just arrived
and remarkable moment is playing out
right now I'll step out and show you
live so we have a group of illegal
immigrants from Venezuela who just
crossed over and are trying to
enter Eagle Pass illegally through all
the bar wire you can see all these
Republicans here that is the GOP
delegation led by the house Speaker they
just got to witness what happens here
every single day the St the state of
Texas has put up these shipping
containers and this barbed wire here and
these Venezuelans came in and were
asking us saying Auda Auda where's the
entrance let us in uh asking where
Border Patrol was well this is Texas and
there's no border patrol here and Texas
is not letting these illegal immigrants
in one of them asked us where's the
president where's the President Lorenzo
if we can pan to the left real quick
here we got more of them in the river uh
the Republicans were saying earlier they
were surprised that how uh dead it was
here in igle pass that there were no
Crossings well here they are now they're
starting to come the delegation is here
they're getting to see what happens here
in Eagle Pass and it was just a
remarkable moment to have all these guys
trying to cross here right in front of
these uh nearly 60 House Republicans who
have come down to the Border here today
uh and you can see the results here they
have not been able to enter so far
because Texas has this barbed wire and
these shipping containers and uh they've
been asking for help there's no border
patrol here and Texas is not letting
them in just a short time ago we spoke
to some of the House Republicans who are
here here's some of what they had to say
when I asked them is this just another
dog and pony show take a
listen we're hoping that some of our
colleagues who don't share shut the
government down or shut the border we
want them to see how how real this is
because if you don't come down to the
Border you don't know and the way we're
going to be able to make that happened
is by the folks that are listening to
your broadcast to call up their
representatives and say we are not going
to tolerate The Invasion that's taken
place on our Southern border any
longer and here's what house Speaker
Mike Johnson tweeted yesterday uh when
it looked like Eagle Pass was having no
activity he said in part quote here's
Eagle Pass just weeks ago versus
yesterday the Biden Administration
decided to divert the flood of illegal
immigrants to another location in order
to keep them out of the camera shots
during the house gop's visit to Eagle
Pass don't be fooled they are still
being released into our country under
President Biden our Southern border is a
disaster and the numbers just
jaw-dropping Martha take a look at this
graphic here CBP sources telling fox in
the month of December alone there were
more than 302,000 migrant encounters at
our Southern border that is the highest
single month ever recorded in US history
and you can see how it compares to
recent Decembers in past years including
a couple of trump years Trump's worst
December was in 2020 when he had about
74 th000 migrant encounters we have now
quadrupled that this last December back
out here live those guys from Venezuela
still trying to get in right now we'll
pan off to the right really quick the
Republican delegation now getting a a
briefing and a tour from Texas DPS all
about 60 of them again led by Speaker
Mike Johnson and they just got a taste
of what happens out here in Eagle Pass
every single day most of the people
crossing out here are Venezuelans and
for now they can't get in because of
this Texas DPS razor wire which the
Biden Administration is fighting in
court right now to uh try to have border
agents be able to rip that wire out
we'll send it back to you incredible oh
lot of dichotomy on that border right
now Bill maluan thank you very much so
back to the Border live when the
pressure gets underway we're going to
head down there we'll listen to the
speaker Mike Johnson it is extraordinary
that this group is touring this area and
not far from them there are lots of
migrants who are crossing over that open
area in the barb wire which the Biden
White House wants remove moved that is
protecting some of these areas and
making it at least a little more
difficult for people to cross it it is
um quite something to see hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else